hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Christmas shopper
simulator to be honest I don't even know
why this game exists and to be more
honest I'm confused that so many people
demanded that I play it I get a
character I can be familiar mail I'll be
mail for now cuz that's what I think I
am there's no reception in here but you
can find out what to do from this
antique payphone okey-dokey then
okay uncle Steve loves shampoo by
Summits crowns land then take it to the
grotto to send it to him
okay so as far as I can tell this is
made by the British game selling company
called game and they made it just as a
joke it's totally free you can play for
yourself in the description below
there's a link so go ready rinse and
repeat
okay go to scrounge lad hundred percent
off that doesn't seem good for business
whose ends agarrado to be shipped what's
the grotto is this some british thing
that i don't even know hey here but it
was 100% free what is the world ok so I
get it they made this game to
intentionally be broken it's mine
talking about
whose are numbers that free screw you
and your face ok I paid for it with no
dollars I got an achievement cheaper
okay so I gotta take it to the grotto
whatever that means
wait a Santa's at the grotto what are
you doing lady you're a little weird
[ __ ] head down kick you right in the
Gabba swirling me mama scuse me
whoa cool okay did not know that this
game involved this sorry lady
you were just dancing what have I done
to you I gotta admit it's mines me love
goat simulator I'm pretty sure that's
for good reason
okay good thing that I go to the mall to
complete missions
I know it's polar double express am I
gonna be picking up porn I gotta be
picking up polar bear porn
what's a jumper what is going on why how
and why
how are you back lady yeah sorry yeah
you're sorry I'm sorry too boy okay high
and wide
are they pants soda jumper is are the
shoes you're a mannequin hey take it I
want to pay for us I want to pay for the
sir sir
well there's a thing why not get the
right one
well screw you okay I went bald for a
second okay thank you oh this one asked
the reindeer on it oh you know I can't
tell you from the manikins so you're all
creepy whoa okay we're off and ready to
go dad yeah thank you lady thank you for
helping me out we sorry
all right yeah all the way Sam thank you
Lisa loves watching documentaries about
a inspire the largest TV I can find well
that doesn't make it easy Oh cuz ants
are small Oh even blue okay so I need oh
oh I remember this okay this is not
normal
Oh scuse me okay all right okay sorry
keep knocking you over I don't mean to
do that
all right okay then stan is weird
surprise gift somebody dropped the game
and shot it and ruffington I could sneak
out and trade it in for an extra game
extra cash and guess what okay whatever
I need to go up all the way if this gate
wasn't free I'd be criticizing it but
it's free and you know what it's it's
all right
okay okay I don't know what the
announcement lady is doing but uh gate
I'm just gonna sneak I'm a sneaky stager
they'll never catch me now I don't know
why the game companies encouraging this
illicit behavior of stealing and trading
in it for money because that's a thing
that actually happens fully poseable
jenny wants a life-sized doll because
she is normal fire life-sized doll from
the cue store ah that's not normal on
multiple levels oh I can't criticize
let's get Lucy your stupid thing
give me a life-size doll give me a love
doll oh ah
all right fine then it's getting fun yet
am I having fun oh I see ha ha ha
ah well one really creepy life-sized
doll
coming right up little Lucy Who am I
doing this for anyway
am I really Santa there before I
distinctly remember Sammy I like that
I'll use that later sigh man a big guy
buy a new pair of double XL jeans from
wide load don't ask why just do it you
calling me fat all right then excuse me
sorry this is done there we go I need to
buy thank you sorry no that was a door
but whatever I'm completing missions
like a boss seriously everyone told me
to play this game literally like other
youtubers told me to play this game oh
you guys told me to play this game dads
yeah where am I going why am I doing
this wait what do you want for me I
gotta break these open yeah Ellie wishes
she was a panda don't we all buy a panda
mess from heads are us check the crates
okay so I don't got a break ah ah didn't
have enough I bet it's in one of the
crates that got stuck back there isn't
it it is I see one there it is I see it
in there god damn it
damn you to hell okay I kept errantly
gotta do everything over again because I
wasn't able to do it right give me this
thank you okay I'm on my way there's
gonna be lightning fast scuse me right
we gotta move
okay thank you
all right give it damn it Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
gift gift gift gift gift gift of gab
lady you're the thing you're the person
I give you gotta be kidding me
you gotta be kidding me you do not need
those pants yes yes okay this is where I
was before okay so now I'm actually
gonna continue from where I was before
which means I need to be very careful
about these demands okay what's next
for a free it's kind of fun might be
good for a good Christmas is hero cats
the girl is nicked a computer from PCs
and pasties PCs and pasties as in nipple
pcs I like your attitude okay by then
I'll just take this to the grotto
Santa's really weird grotto oh dressing
up on tealy and still think she's a bear
find her a costume it's cheaper than
therapy all right that sounds normal and
okay
wait a minute wasn't there another one
of these before wait a minute do me hi
ha ha my way what do you think you're
doing young man get outta my okay this
somehow what in the world
everyone's British here this is how
things happen in London if you didn't
know that is what Christmas shopping is
all about Merry Christmas have a bone
easy baking head to the cue store to get
the special oven for the bedroom pies in
bed I thought that said piss in bed I
really thought that was pistol bit yeah
damn Oh why's it gotta be all the way up
there ok how's anybody supposed to do
this ok this thing's heavy
well I didn't do it ok I can't jump
apparently what can I jump is it really
yeah B Oh fine I'll go down the stairs
yet dingleberry dammit dammit this isn't
the right way this dude oh there we go
got it okay I win thank you what's next
excuse me holy night go to the game
store defeat the Black Knight and seize
his legendary sword Marvel its shininess
okay oh come here you [ __ ] what are you
doing what are you doing we don't we
don't green on you [ __ ] whoa what did I
just see a little bit of a replay of
what the hell just happened
ma'am your big sward mr. black hey can I
please Oh
party's over apparently okay then I have
a sword okay
so what am I doing this am i taking this
to the grotto am I really taking a sword
to deliver to the boys and girls all
around town I think I just killed that
lady thank you for choosing us for your
pretend shopping okay and I really don't
know if I'm supposed to stop playing now
I keep seeing that really creepy thing I
can if I press f whoa everything got
really quiet I guess I've reached sir
Nirvana or some booboo key I broke the
game yeah all right then so I guess I'm
all done I literally couldn't find
anything else to do before I broke the
game which was bound to happen
eventually so it's a fun game to spend
some time especially these fries check
the link in the description below if I
miss anything write in the comments down
below I won't make another episode but
other people may want to find out for
themselves so let me know in the
comments what you think of this game
it's a fun low experience Merry
Christmas everybody happy holidays even
though it's not that
yet so thanks again everybody for
watching check out all the silly stuff
and Christmas related crap that I've
done in the past in the description
below or the annotation over there
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video